en france le président de république
nicolas sarkozy accompagné par son
épouse carla bruni depuis lundi en
vacances au cap [ __ ] dans la résidence
des bruni-tedeschi une maison située à
quelques kilomètres du fort de brégançon
résidence officielle du président de la
république et pour la première fois
aujourd'hui nicolas sarkozy ait quitté
l'enceinte priver de cette propriété
pour une sortie renaud bernard et
nicolas ou r pour certains c'est l'heure
de l'apéro
pour nicolas sarkozy c'est le premier
jogging de vacances à la fraîche il y à
quelques minutes à la semaine et comme
tout le monde la semaine qu en plus des
sports oms lyon se repose votre étrange
aussi propose coup de téléphone
et puis on se repose là toute la journée
nicolas sarkozy est resté à l'abri du
portail de cap [ __ ] la résidence chic
et discrète de vacances de son épouse
carla bruni mais la connaissez
c'est très calme il ya personne
vraiment pour l'instant pas s'il y avait
du monde ils ont été très discret en
tout cas la discrétion à quelques
détails très des patrouilles sur les
routes comme en mer et une
réglementation spéciale mise en place
sur la zone pour l'occasion d'un saut
l'interdiction qui lui c'est le survol
de
de la pointe du cap d'agde pour les
avions mais après il ya aucune
restriction au pied de la maison sur la
plage
les vacanciers sont tous impatients
d'apercevoir à nouveau le couple
présidentiel je les vois la télé mais
pas pour de vrai ça serait bien qu'ils
viennent à cette plage une chose est
sûre au cap [ __ ] le tourisme
présidentielle est déjà en place du cap
[ __ ]
ludo résidence du couple où il a fait ça
pour lui
pour les marchands de souvenirs l'avenir
et souriant mise à part un déplacement
en chine
nicolas sarkozy et son épouse vont
rester dans la région jusqu'au 15 août
et puis un peu